[Music]
hi hello to everyone so today i'm going
to show you
how i experienced
in front of my own one interesting
positional motive and this happened in
1994 during the famous olympiad in
moscow so you may say okay maybe i mean
the age you are there you should have
known this module well probably i have
seen it already earlier but i some kind
of didn't have this recollection
and it was the game which first i'm
going to show you was played on this
olympiad which like i thought it was
quite memorable because we won against
russia
and the russian team was with
kasparov and
kramnik i played a draw with fiddler
kasparov got checkmate on the
seventh rank by topalov venusillian in a
rather crushing defeat so it was quite
interesting communicating won against uh
georgiev and his past one against draft
at the end of course russia became
olympia champions something which
recently they they can accomplish
probably there is some reason so the
quality maybe is not the same but okay
they have to discover what what is
happening they can become like olympia
champions so the game i'm going to show
you was played in the 11 round and it is
a game
by afghani breath with white and gory
girl godzilla so the game itself was not
like a difficult one so this personal
motive and then i searched and i found
incredible examples by the great mikhail
tao of the same personal motive which is
an exchange sacrifice at the square e6 a
rather an interesting you know
positional decision so in this game
which was played in 1995 repeat moscow
d4 and g6 e4 c6
h3 well usually play knight c3 d5 h3 but
especially this system of the bishop g7
knight c3 and d5 white has two ways to
play so one of them is without h3 just
to play e5 and f4 is very aggressive but
also a very calming piston opponent is
the one you are seeing now with knight
f3 well curiously enough this system for
black had a very strange name
in bulgaria it's called the red system
why i don't know it beats me i don't
know the reason why we call the system
you know the red but it has this
peculiar name i know how it is this
system in english in my like base i call
it like systems with g6
so
i mean but in bulgaria clearly it has
the name the red system so here after uh
the prophylactic h3
white is ready to develop their piece
quite comfortably and in this game black
plays 96 one of the popular continuation
and just to give you a little bit of
information on knight f6 we play e5 94
capture on e4 and then we play knight g5
and then e6 so this like the most
unpleasant line for black so neither six
it's curiously that one year before i
have played against you know this with
knight h6 which seems quite you know
uh not a very logical development bishop
f4 and here i think the main the line
goes like f6 because this knight wants
to go to f7 we take on d5 knight b5 and
then c4 so this i think was one of the
main lines and here black just exchanged
in the center and play knight five just
something to mention to mention if black
give check on a5 you have to be ready to
go into the end game because c3 allows
this curious double attack and you have
to exchange you know the dark squared
bishop which is something you prefer not
to do so you prefer to play queen e2 and
now this end game in my opinion
yes it's an end game but with rather you
know peculiar developed pieces by black
and with a clear lack of space so if you
continue liking this end game here
g3
castle along castle i like very much a
white picture i think it's much easier
to play and after 97 and you continue
with this problems where to
find any suitable place for your pieces
like on bishop a6
of course when i have more space i'm
going to leave even more peace on the
broad not that if i exchange and don't
hit on dodge but even more plan just to
play bishop h2 and rookie one so let's
not delve so much into here the
theoretical because our main theme is
this exchange sacrifice at the square e6
so in this game knight t5 was played by
gergatze c3 and white continues
developing their piece in a very natural
central way castle bishop d3 in the game
i played
in 1993 in
one open in catalonia black played a5
and after castle they played knight e6
of course in this way i mean what can
you expect why he has very easier play
and in this game after rookie knight
seven although my point was like a solid
nintendo so the game was pretty easy
because okay you just you know
positionally your strength quite well
and black always find it very difficult
to find any trace of count to play and
in this game they start weakening some
squares and then well they were
positionally demolished so continue with
our games get rather play 96
castle knight take on e4 bishop take on
e4 now in my opinion it looks a little
bit more logical to play in 96 97 still
not a very pleasant pission but they
continue to the typical car confection
97
rookie one
knight f6
and after bishop c2 in this mission with
less space they played a really careless
move and this happened like i've been
telling you in front of my house they
allowed this very standard sacrifice by
playing bishop physics and of course
baref which is a classical chess player
which started all the you know the
classical
chess games he didn't spend too much
executing this
exchange sacrifice which in this
circumstances is much easier than the
examples i'm going to show you
in the taos game so look take on e6 pawn
take on e6 and knight g5 the base of
this exchange sacrifice that now you're
always going to feel weak on the light
squares because their point is going to
have a piece very strong on this quest
which is the light squared bishop and
you're not going to have the natural
defender plus your pawn structure is
clearly you know damaged and
having an extra bishop on the light
squares you know makes also the chances
of a kickstarter thing very real so
basically for the exchange you have a
very easy play and in this game and it
was really quite comfortable for white
so here for example they played knight
d5
you know the other lines white's
initiative goes you know very smoothly
here
if they don't want to allow this super
knight on e6 they have to play e5 but
still the position of the king is not
really something to
envy bishop take on e5 is quite good
even with the pawn he's not bad at all
because now
the king side attack is also you know
quite easy to spot now we are
threatening c4 so
uh after knight g5 he will play like
queen c8 also black is very passive and
don't be surprised here in their opinion
is quite difficult because one of the
main questions you can see on the road
exactly how black
has been held by the rook from a8 so you
have the sensation that
uh why is it taken with an extra piece
and this is like a very real cessation
so in this game gergazzo played knight
d5 and georgio was a very solid
grandmaster
then he became
i think um
the chief of the uh
georgian uh chess federation i think
after as my president purpose was
machine but then he became of the euro
european chess union and maybe even
nowadays
but a very solid grandmaster no so 95
bishop g3
he defended the pawn queen g4 with a
tempo not only attacking only 6 but
transferring the queen on the very weak
king side which now who is going to
protect the light squares this is a
problem now if you play rook f6 to
defend the pawn after queen h4 basically
getting demolished i mean the next move
is going to be knight c5 so very bad
now if you play knight f6 looking like a
move with a tempo the opponent is not
going to change the queens which is
going to be very much relieved no he's
going to play queen e2
he's going to bring all of the pieces
but
and especially the light squad bishop is
doing something you know exceptional
damage so in this game
black out of necessity with obvious
problems they decide to give back
material when the pawn which is still
remain so rook five rookie one there is
no no hurry to capture back the exchange
knight f6 and now bishop take on f5
making full use that you can capture on
ge4 because you're going to continue
losing material a lot of material by
capturing here take knight akonysix the
knight is hanging and if the knight goes
back knight take on g7 drop take on e7
look take on b7 basically
the black piston is falling apart
because they are losing everything
so after bishop take on f5
they captured with the e pawn if you
capture with a g pawn well i mean the
pawn e6 is weak the king side is
terrible very bad so e take on f5
queen e2 rookie well
black
managed somehow to keep some sort of a
no not completely lost vision but
positionally they're standing quite bad
and maybe this was the reason why you
know very quickly they made a tactical
blunder because probably they were quite
disappointed by the especially in a team
championship you feel quite bad when you
get slowly such terrible position so 96
and when you have a knight on e6 usually
this is not a very good sign now you
have to play knight e4 because if you
play bishop h8 knight 7 with the tempo
and quintex on e7 so 94 knight take on
g7 and here of course they should have
played king g7 check on e5 and we have a
position in which white have clearly the
better minor piece a much safer king and
a better pawn structure and more active
pieces but at least the game is not over
no although they have a clear picture of
edge and instead of that here the game
made it very quickly by back playing
knight take on g3 and i just blended
this the so-called intermediate move
queen e5 after queen e5
they lose a lot of material so that's
why they resign
not a very complex way but it became you
know interesting for me okay let's take
a look if i can find some better example
interesting examples with this
interesting rook take on e6 motif and i
found in the hands of one of the
greatest chess players that existed in
the great michiel tao
so here he's a game he played with a
international master from bulgaria and
who for quite some time she played on
the olympias at the team for bulgaria in
the early years and i had even one
chance to play against him when i
managed to to get my first international
masternode just before i went into the
military for two years which was then
you know needed to do in bulgaria so i
played with uh atanascular of the
appoint of tao and i won a very nice
game with black although he was the same
[ __ ] but he played at this tournament
now
before i show you this very nice example
of the game of tao here in the same
system which tao played against claru i
remembered because i have seen one of
these very rare examples i'm not going
to show the whole game but of botvinnik
which played at the end of the sixties
in the team championship in uh the
ex-soviet union
in the before
you know russia it was soviet union he
played against a completely unknown
opponent
uh this type of vision and he got
completely annihilated although you've
never heard of his name his name is
booyakin and okay i mean i don't know
what kind of eloquent but this is a very
rare example just to show the opening
when but finnick played the kind of a
red system like the game we watched and
he got a very bad opening vision
although the move rather was quite
interesting d4 g6 knight c3 back his
opponent he wants to play e4 d5 and now
he transports into this system so bishop
g7 knight f3 the idea on bishop g4 is to
play you know bishop c4 and to threaten
you know capturing on f7 so both play
knight d7 bishop c4 exactly what we are
going to see in the game of tao so
that's why i want just to show the
opening of this game knight b6 bishop b3
a5 so but winning tried to play very
originally but you know you can invent
chess again even against not a famous
player when he played just classically
in the center the results were quite bad
for the thing so t3
a3 bishop c2 knight f6
now a very common team you just deprived
black of castle so the result of the
opening are quite poor here for black
but routine tried to compensate with
this super original maneuver with the
rook but it didn't help very much
quincy one rook jade well trying to trap
the bishop but the bishop just goes to
f4 whistling away and saying okay do you
think that your ideas have you know any
rational you know uh meaning rookie one
g5
bishop e5 no of course black patient
makes a very poor impression because i
mean they have pushed the a pawn the g
pawn you can never believe this was
about finnick playing with black but yes
he was but finnick and then here after
rook take on e5 knight take on e5 he
gave up this pawn the opponent captured
the pawn and then step by step he
realized his advantage basically with an
iron technique without you know
making like a wrong step so this was a
game played in 1968. now why i showed
this game because the same scheme we're
going to see in the game of tao with
kolarov played in a european
uh team championship in 1970
so let's take a look at this game so
karakan was played and after knight c3
the international master from bulgarian
opted
for
like i've told you the so-called system
the red system which we call it in
bulgaria knight f3 by tao
bishop g7 and now h3 we've already
looked at knight h6 the original game
when i saw you know the exchange
sacrifice on e6 now
in this game collar opted for taking on
e4 and playing knight d7 now you know
that if you play knight f6 immediately
i'm going to capture and play bishop h6
which is quite unpleasant so 97 bishop
c4
knight f6 knight take on f6
no need to repeat that bishop take on f6
is going to be punished by bishop h6
it's not winning by false but it's quite
unpleasant position now
knight ache on f6 by quarrel here the
problematic piece that's why we
developed the bishop on c4 which is an
active square is the bishop from c8
now castle
castle rookie one
black tried to solve the problem of this
piece by putting it into a more active
position like bishop f5 and of course
they are dreaming if they can exchange
this bishop for
its colleague the light square white
bishop but let's see if tao is going to
permit that 95 basically trying to avoid
any kind of exchanges by black here for
example you can play knight d7 and to
try to because the the basic idea here
by black if you exchange a couple of
minor pieces then of course the space
advantage of white is not going to be of
a great importance because they you
don't have so many pieces to find them
like a normal location and black is very
solid but white is preventing then
that's why tao played 95 if you play
knight d7 you're permitting a quite
common tactic geforce you're going to
lose material
on knight d5 probably that would have
played bishop b3 of course he's not
going to play bishop g5 and you know to
allow the frog kf6 so bishop b3 bishop
e6 so this
also makes sense you want to play knight
c7 at least to exchange a couple of
minor piece here white can play t3 and
knight c7 and here one idea aggressive
niche try to use the h pawn to try to
provoke some weakening on the king side
it makes sense because here you can play
h5 this is an important detail
because you play h5 i have this
you know not a very complex tactic
knight g6 and by playing h4 when you
take on b3 at least you are activating
one of my pieces with a tempo the queen
so this that's why h4 is not a bad idea
so here and queen take on b3 just to
give you some ideas here
kwarov tried to put the light squared
bishop into some decent pigeon he played
after 95 bishop e4 moving to d5 tao
reacted with bishop g5 bishop d5 and of
course he avoid exchanges by playing
bishop d3 now the bishop is a like
some kind of a limbo now and kevin
minded the rook from e1 and the bishop
on g5 are looking
at the on e7 so he tried to took some
medals he played bishop b6 c3
now knight d7
well on 95 also the patient is you know
more unpleasant for sure for
black so he tried to cause some exchange
but of course tao is avoiding them he
plays knight f3
now the next move allowed
what what is our main team the
sacrifice on e6 maybe he thought that
he'll have time to play knight of eight
or maybe he thought that in this
position
rook takonis is nothing to worry so much
because you have knight of fate then no
and okay let's face it you are
sacrificing just exchange not even for a
pawn
but it's so strong positional idea
especially in this pawn structure
because it's going to be combined by
obvious vision of pressure on the light
squares plus weak king side and tao is
going to show us this you know in a very
convincing way probably it was better to
play knight fix here although the same
sacrifice which is not like an
obligation here you can just play queen
e2 and queen d2 and then you know
mobilize the second rook but rook take a
music also here is quite interesting
just to show a couple of lines in queen
d6 and you're going to see this just a
positional idea here bishop d2 bishop d2
is played to prepare knight g5
so reminding you that the king side is
quite shaky if you play knight f4 i'm
going to change one of the bishops but
i'm going to get something in return
here of course i'm capturing immediately
and on this move i have
you know an immediate you know very
obvious initiative on the light squares
more than obvious no now if you take
on this check if you play king h8 i'm
going to take queen take on e7 already i
have opponent and still
you know you have problems on the king
side and prawns on the on the light
squares and the bishop is looking at the
pawn d4 so not a very brilliant piece
also
a clear personal compensation here no
and i have two pawns yeah because i've
taken on e6 and e7 i even you know
didn't see this immediately but now with
two pawns a clear advantage of white no
so if you play here after
bishop d2 if you take with rukun f4 just
playing knight g5 with the tempo
and
how you're going to sustain the pressure
on the light squares is a mystery if you
play bishop f6 then white proceeds with
h4
and now h5 is a real real threat no and
then the battery you know you always
have to think about the battery queen
queen e4 so you play knight f4 i'm
capturing
playing g3 and then h5
and it's clear that the attack is super
strong here i mean
i don't know how you're going to survive
the last move queen h5 was threatening
checkmate on a7 though so here rook take
then okay here it's a completely in my
opinion resign number operation very bad
one so even after knight f6
here
rook tekken 86 was quite good but here
quarter of played rook e8 hoping that
the knight from f8 is going to be more
useful but it allowed the sacrifice even
in worse circumstances for black rook
takuni 6 pawn takes and now queen 2 i
just want to capture on e6 if you play
knight f8 let's take a look
bishop f4 preparing you know now knight
g5
queen a5 bishop c4 all the right beasts
are coming and the great question is
exactly how it's helping the rook from
a8
yes you say maybe later no but maybe
later there'll be no game maybe the game
will be finished because the rooks need
to open fires when they're crawling on
the back crane and there is clear
initiative especially in towards the
king then not much use of the extra
exchange so bishop c4 let me show you
some line queen here queen e3 just
keeping all the active pieces here
rookie one
so you see the initiative is coming in a
very natural way bishop take on e6 with
a tempo no knight take on e6 yes now you
don't have the light squared bishop but
already the weaknesses on the king's
side are more than glaring no now the
dark squares are a big problem here
knight take on d8 and okay you have like
a lost end game so after queenie two
probably quarter saw that here
it looks not you know there here so he
said okay let me give back material
immediately he played e5 let's try to
close some files but like many great
players have experienced it was very
difficult to close files against mcgill
tower against you know this real chess
wizard almost impossible so e5 bishop c4
check
king h8 pawn takes on e5 still plums
with space and the pair bishop is still
quite annoying queen c7
and now we have good use of the light
squad bishop because ok he is the only
one who is dominating on the light
squares bishop f7 by tao now
one of the ideas when you're under
serious pressure is to give back
material well it's a good idea but it's
also not functioning perfectly here if
you play
knight take
on e5 bishop take e8 now if you take on
f3 here
i just play
queen f7 which basically is a double
attack and an unpleasant one now rook d8
rookie one you're going to lose material
if you play queen d7 or one
so you're going to be a pawn down
probably in a lost end game if after
bishop take only 8 you capture with the
rook then we play rook d1
why because in almost no position the
rook strives to be on open files here at
least you're going to lose a pawn
because take a look at the pawn
structure not only all the white pieces
are more active but the pawn structure
black has three pawn island
like on the queen side the pawn e7 and
on the king side the white is much
better he has very much more compact
pawn structure than two pawn islands and
of course more active pieces so here if
you play like
rook d8 on rook fade we just play queen
d3 and take full control
of the only open file which is the
default and probably with bad cons on
this move rook d8 there is a simple
double attack so you lose a pawn then
white is not losing anything of the
official advantage so after the move
bishop f7 quarter was reluctant to give
back material no he didn't see that he
gets something up and he played through
cafe his mission
did not become better after this move
you know to be honest so here e6
now of course this combination of bishop
f6 and e6 keeps the black king always in
big danger no if you play for example
knight e5
we captured e5 and now the pawn e7 is a
problem and you have to capture here
with the bishop because okay if you
capture with the queen this is i mean
very easily one pission because now for
the exchange i have
how many points let me count it so two
pawns and the pony probably very soon is
going to be promoted if we continue for
example
rfd8 or c8 f4
because we are threatening you can't
capture the pawn because bishop f6 is a
checkmate with a pair bishop here and
rookie and rogue d7 so very bad on this
move we're going to play rook d7
no need to continue here further because
obviously the pawn is scrolling forward
so obvious here so let's capture with
the bishop on e5
and now probably the most technically
just play queen e3 what's the idea of
queen e3 you may ask well the idea is
just to prevent bishop f4 you want to
keep this piece on the boat so queen
here
rook d8 rookie one attacking the bishop
now
the problem is that you can never play
bishop f6 because after the exchange
he's going to play e7 big problem no so
if you play
bishop d6 here then queen d4
and checkmate
or you lose everything no so let's play
bishop g7
and now the fact that white even can
play such a move although of course it's
not the only move but if this move is
efficient then your operation is very
bad because you are lacking you know you
have no breathing space so even this
offer to exchange queens if it's
effective because now you're losing the
pawn e7 and then it speaks volumes about
how bad is your opinion and bishop e7
basically can be saved no because
i've already told you why bishop f6 is
not possible no because i capture an e7
if you play here r28 and then queen h4n
okay everything is falling apart i mean
the pawn e7 the king side is falling
apart bishop g6 the bishop f7 turns out
tao felt this perfectly is a very like a
torn in the black pigeon so here claro
played knight f6
now it's time to activate the queen and
okay
if you search for somebody to you know
to find the best way to activate and the
piece of this of course is the genius
mikhail tao quincey four the queen looks
at the square h4 and then after he goes
to h4 the knight is coming to e5
very soon and of course the black king
is going to fill the heat
very much so
queen a5 rook 1 providing the e5 square
and now everything looks very logical
queen h4 and the next move is 95. i mean
you don't have time to capture the poll
because after such a move not the only
move i can even play bishop g6 but okay
this is a complete killer known 95. so
after queen h4 it was obvious that you
can
sustain any more such a tone in your
opinion like bishop f7 so you have to
give back some material and to give back
on exchange rook take on f7 but you
already
still have the pawn weaknesses so you
take on f7
and tao use the chance you want to play
an intermediate move 95. not that he
take on f7 was bad but this is even more
unpleasant no 95 with a tempo now
you can't go back no rook fade because
the knight is going to do what he does
quite well all kind of night forks
knight taken g6 number one and then
knight take on e7 number two
and this will be the end of this game so
typical knight h5 knight acorn f7 bishop
take on e7 we are coming very close
to a technical part of this game and tar
showed also a very nice technique which
that's why
he was such a you know legendary player
rook 8
96
jumping okay if you don't want to lose a
lot of material there is only one move
to do and they played bishop f6
bishop take on f6 and queen take on d6
now temporarily there are two pawns down
but at least they hope you know to take
kunichiks and
maybe to have some very slight you know
chance to save the pigeon very slightly
because they're going to have a pawn
down in a prison with a knight against
the bishop with pawns on both flanks so
basically every end game which is going
to occur looks like with very you know
slim chances to to survive here tao
played bishop g5 bishop d4 also was
quite good but okay there is no need so
every chess player
has his own you know taste how to
realize that right tau chose
bishop g5
because he thought okay here the bishop
is going to be more active rook they
could easily now
he uses the pin so now not only white is
having an extra a pawn but the black
king is also feeling you know a lot of
prawn if the king goes to f7 then sooner
or later this position of the king is
going to be a problem we can play queen
b3 with a tempo attack in the pawn
the pawn is defended but now we have
another open file for the rook meanwhile
there could be six spin which is usually
very bad news and now the whiter can use
a typical highway the third rank and the
rook f3 is coming and probably this is
going to be something you know already
very bad because almost all of the black
pieces have been and the bishop clearly
clearly much better than the knight so
after queen c4 quarter of played knight
g7 and hiatal finished the game by some
you know
of typical temple moves always attacking
something in winning time queen b3 again
attacking the pawn and preparing rook d1
well maybe it was better here to play
queen d5 but okay in my opinion
it will not have saved the game if you
play queen d5 the following end game in
my opinion
is
without much hope because you have the
better minor piece and you have an extra
pawn on the king side you're going to
play f4 bring the king g4 and step by
step i think
realizing that is not going to be
something very difficult after b6 you
can play rook d1
queen c7 and then
check
and okay here the black king is going to
have
very difficult time to survive because
rook d7 is a killer threat so after
queen b3 i point out that king f8 was
like a mistake but okay mistakes in
difficult situation are very easy you
know to come up with mistake because
you're already feeling you know a lot of
problems now
rook d1 making use that the black is
coming you know towards a you know a
central position when of course he's
going to find a lot of dangers with such
active white pieces rook d1 if you go to
c7 check
and then queen d1 i mean if you play
king f7 if you play like
uh 98 then of course the rook is hanging
on e6 not if you play after this
move rook eight maybe the only move
which has remained we capture here and
we give this check to pin basically all
the the black piece if you go king e7
queen j8 and if you pin the knight queen
e6 and okay this is i mean because we
know that the pawn end game is
completely lost with a clear extra pawn
on the king's side
so they played queen e5 and tower
followed with bishop a6 another pin
rook d6 rook take on d6 and here kwarov
resigned because ok
the queen is going to capture on b7
hanky got completely demolished so this
was a nice swing by tao but the next one
in which he employed the same strategic
motive is quite memorable although it's
a blitz game but it's the only win by
tao of
the legendary adversary anatoly kapoor
well we have to be honest that anatoly
carp of high recoil maybe just one win
in many games because they made a lot of
draws so tao in one moment when he
played i guess uh kushner was working
for
uh carp helping him i mean in the match
in baguio also in some other matches so
they made a lot of jaws but i recorded
maybe one win by karpov maybe he has two
but i recall only one
and tau
had
in the first when carp was a young and
very promising grandmaster he had some
good question tao he couldn't win but
this one was a really remarkable victory
and this was by using again
our team after they the exchange
sacrifice on e6 and it's a rather
spectacular game and it's quite
interesting that
natalie karpov has already employed the
same strategic team in a game he played
earlier than the blizz game but of
course in blitzman you have very short
amount of time sometimes you got a
little bit careless although the way the
tao sacrifice on e6 in this game
is maybe the most spectacular one
but on this game okay he liked very much
blitz you get a lot of imagination
you're going to enjoy
really this game now let me first after
e4 c6 that was with white let me first
show you the example not the whole game
because it was like a long game and at
the end
last night was in a severe time trouble
so the game in which karpov in 1979
employed similar exchange sacrifice
against larsen so it was not new for kim
for sure so this game was from 1979 and
cal president and you're going to see
the same exchange sacrifice although in
better conditions for black so e4 c6 the
same opening karu khan
here
uh
karpov played d4 not not in argue he
played d4 d592
and here after 94 knight f6 one of the
rare occasions when karpov played knight
g3 now at least i have not seen many
games again with knight g3 the favorite
line of lakin which i have played almost
exclusively when i was playing blitz
here the twitch streams it's interesting
because it keeps more peace on the board
menolakin was a great tactician okay
also a great personal player the fourth
world champion so he liked to play this
line and there is a famous game against
cover which was played after
e5 knight f3 and here
you know comparing his game with
kerblanca when he captured with the
queen on d4 and that was a a very jewish
endgame this time he captured with the
knight on d4 and tartakov played very
badly this game he got the complete
indicate but his game was really
surprisingly very bad especially in this
one so here just to give a little
information
most of my opponent plays this move h5
which in my opinion is strategically
risky i still keep my opinion no
but in this game
with larsen lassen played a solid move
maybe not the most negative but i think
it's one of the more solid move g6 at
least he tries to you know
to limit the scope of the knight from g3
carpool plate knight f3 i'm showing you
this game just to see
that he also have already tried this
motif exchange sacrifice on e6 bishop g7
bishop p2 castle castle queen b6
b3 karpov with white lassen with black
bishop g4 bishop b2 a5 a4
97 now he gets the pair of bishops rook
d8 queenie two and carp like all the
great players he also of course magnus
carson he likes very much to play
position with a
uh
a special advantage well all the great
players treasure very much you know the
advanced space so rookie one knight f8
queen c4
96 and here karpov employs the same team
rook take on e6 and queen take on easy
check so you see that karpov was quite
familiar you know with this team
and the game went king h8 rookie one
queen before hvac h4 queen is queen h3
he got mischief on the king side
larsen played this game quite well so it
was a complex game but at the end
karpov went because in time trav just
before the first time control larson
really missed quite a few tactics but it
was a complex game no now
so karpov was quite familiar with this
team now let's take a look at this
brilliant bliss game of the super you
know incredible chess player mikhail tao
and his only victory
as far as i know over natalika so e4 c6
c4 well one of the lines against the
calico is attack pan off i've played it
quite often
i usually play it like that like d4 d5
in the pure from and now c4 yeah so you
see that against the character you have
very different system
so and
nowadays for example after d4 d5 the
world champion magnus likes to play very
often e5 and on bishop f5 he plays also
a system based on a space and dutch with
c4 an active one after for example ce5 i
remember that
at the end of august
in the previous year 21 when there was
many online tournaments he's got a very
impressive victory against nordic in one
of these online tournaments i think it
was aim chess rapid at the end of focus
he played this curious line which was
a line also employed by the legendary
michael tao so he employed this exotic
line take on c5 e6 and now taos move
queen g4
which is one of these rare exceptions
when the queen goes out early but
prevents black from developing easily
their king side and he's got a very good
win against nordic i mean just to show
the first move and it was about
development so noriski played 97
knight f3 capturing on c5 bishop e2
97
getting to f5 at least to defend the
king side but magnus carson opened up
the pission when he has acute elite in
development and has got a rather
impressive win so
just to see how similarities between
these great players so in this bliss
game tau played
c4 and karpov d5 of course karpov has
played carol khan basically
throughout his whole career how it
started he started with
the candidates matches when for the
first time he employed against pasqui
like a big surprise it was a big
surprise and he played it very well then
of course he didn't play it for a long
period of time and then he started to
employ back especially against kasparov
in the latest matches and also
when he played also against kamsky
against uh sukhov in this candies match
in you know in the latest you know
periods of his career but he was quite
successful with khao khan his way of
playing calcan was mainly
in the earlier stages when he employed
for the first time against basket played
in a classical way with a bishop f5 then
against kasparovki played with the
fourth move after capturing on e4 97 so
okay his stage changed a little bit so
here against a tao they played here and
tao captured twice on d5 and we have a
sort of a version of the pawn of attack
slightly different knight f6 knight c3
knight aching a5 knight f3 so this like
a kind of a different move road which
i've seen a colleague of mine uh
grandmaster connect employed with white
in a good way so knight f3 knight take
on c3 well carp liked to take on c3 he
employed also against rokoff in their
match in the in the candidates in a much
you know later year so he likes you know
this pawn structure when white has the
so-called
hanging pawns in the center of course
the hanging pawns are much more dynamic
than the isolated pawn
knight taken c3 of course he uses this
moment when you know you can capture
with a d-pawn because okay you're not
going to go in the end game without you
know any chance to get even a symbolic
advantage it's absurd so b take on c 3
by tau g 6
d
bishop g7 now bishop d3 it's the better
mover because bishop c4 allows queen g7
and okay
you start having some trouble how to
develop the b in the way you want so now
you have to play queen b3 and the queen
b3 gives time to the opponent after late
he plays knight six no
not very comfortable of course you don't
want you want to exchange pieces by
giving check bishop to e7 also not very
logical so that's why it's the better
move always bishop d3 just what tau
played bishop d3 castle castle
knight six
rookie one and now rookie i think it's
more logical here to play with bishop g4
striving for e5 of course we're not
going to look theoretically at the blitz
game but this i think is probably the
best way here there is some theory with
bishop e4 and so on but this is like the
most solid line for black in this
particular opening position now after
rookie one carp employed a solid move
even in blitz oh he was a great [ __ ]
player like all of these great champions
so rookie 8
and now bishop g5
now you still can play bishop g4 but in
my opinion this is under world
circumnate because e5 is not going to be
an option anymore so this is like an
important detail no and this was like
the point
of white playing bishop g5 by tao he
wants to prevent any e5 no so after
bishop g5 carelessly here there are
other moves like queen d6 makes more
sense queen d2 and so but carelessly
carpool played bishop p6 and he allowed
rook taikonisiks well he thought that
maybe in this circumstance it's not
going to be a big problem no
but okay you have to be like a put here
in my comments you have this tendency to
be more careless in a bliss games and i
know even if you play on trimmings
sometimes and you make a move by your
hand and then you see oh how i played
this move i should have played another
one it happens no so even the great
players can
make
some kind of inaccuracy so
bishop p6 and tao of course didn't need
like a second invitation to make
one of exchange a girl he was very much
familiar with so rook taken
26 bishop e6
now we start pressing on the light
squares and we are not forgetting about
the opponent's king now in the game
karma played 26 defending the pawn if he
gives up the pawn immediately well in my
opinion we are much more interested here
on the chances on the king side that's
why here i look mainly in the bishop e3
we have some other moves which are okay
but this probably is the most unpleasant
because it creates knight g5 as a rather
unpleasant threat how we can defend if
you play like windy six this move is
already you know bringing all the white
pieces which is a problem no if you play
like queen a5
the idea of queen a5 is to defend with
this move by vacating the square d8 for
the knight but white also can correct
their way of action they can take bishop
take on e6 and now if you take on c3
rook c1 and then knight g5
bishop b3 and
we have obvious ideas like queen g4
queen h4 or even start pushing the h
pawn black position looks very passive
even druk from a8 is quite upset because
the knight from d8 is taking his only
chance to play in the game so not very
happy now if you play
not capturing the pawn but you play
first uh knight eight we just go back
oh okay i've looked even bishop december
bishop b3 is not bad at all bishop d7
and queen b3 also looks
quite unpleasant for black and this is
me being polite so another option after
bishop b3 at least to get some
activities to play e5 but then the code
diagonal is glaringly weak no after
rookie fade we are not going to give
black the chance
to get back material by you know taking
r7 and taking default we're going to
play in a much more efficient way we're
going to play
knight e6 and after here we're going to
take on f8 and then play d5 and we're
going to enjoy
a pair of bishops and
quite
bad in my opinion black pawns touch i
mean here i don't like the application
e4 bishop take on a7 and the bishop
start doing their damage here for
example the king is also not something
to be remembered
so here after bishop c4
carpool decided okay we're going to
stick to the pawn and played queen e6
very typical of karp of no solid defense
queen 2 renewing the thread and 98 this
was the point of 26 no
to keep this square and meanwhile the g5
square is still not available no so
white needs some time to re reorganize
their pieces carpenter for this time
he's going to be able to create some
counter play let's see quinito attacking
on e6 knight d8 rookie one bringing all
the pieces very typical tau this is a
sign of a great player look c8
try
here for example we also see
the other his opponent that he's also a
great player because he found a way to
regroup his peace and to include
everything even drug from a8 now he's
you know doing some kind of action 92 by
tao now of course he is creating the
chance later on this night to go to e4
and the h pawn now is ready maybe to go
forward and don't forget this is a bliss
game if you play here for example queen
c7 probably that would have started
pushing the h pawn
now karpov took some precautions here
and played king h8
which is a pre-or prophylactic no
because at least he don't have to worry
capturing on e6 with the temple but now
when the king is on the h vowel the
pushing of the h pawn looks very very
logical because it's a blitz game
tower first played 94 h4 immediately
probably is even much more unpleasant
but we can be critical of such a
brilliant blitz game no
it will be a little bit too much so here
tau played 94 typical temple move for a
blizzard the queen goes back bishop b3
and now he is ready to push the h spawn
but karpov make use of the prophylactic
nh8 and start starting with counter play
e5
wanting some activity now it fight wants
to be successful he doesn't have to lose
any time at all and this is what mikhail
did he don't look here to play like
d5 or something he start pushing the
h-ball he wants to give checkmate now
no here precautions on the kingside is
going to give any relief so if you
include the move h6
then bishop d2 capturing queen g4 you
see all the white pieces are coming and
probably the end is going to be a
checkmate
like here if you continue the line and
after this move you're really going to
get checkmate because now i'm
threatening queen
h6 checkmate
and
i don't know how you're going and the
other threat of course obvious is queen
take
on
e8 so how you're going to prevent
everything is a bit of a mystery
to me no i don't know how you're going
to prevent everything but probably
you're going to get checkmate here
like one other thing which i'm
looking at let's take a look if you play
like
knight f7
how are you going to give
the easiest way to give
checkmate
queen f7 you take only one do i have a
checkmate
um
what will be
no bishop take on f7 yeah yeah so this
is like
no bishop take on f7 simply it's not and
it's not keeping nothing and i'm still
threatening queen eliza checkmate and so
yeah the situation is quite hopeless so
after h486 is just weakening even more
the king side
not very good so that's why they
continuously to you know to try to
create some countess by capturing on d4
and there follows h5 now the heat is on
let's see what black can do to defend
and especially this in time trouble and
you're always in time travel when you
play this game it's very difficult to
defend this type especially against
you know the most dangerous attacking
player like michael tao now let's take a
look at some black options if you play
let's first just the most favorable we
just captured the pawn c3 then we
capture on g6
and we are threatening just to give
checkmate on the h file now we try to
block the bishop the queen goes here we
try to defend
and okay here of course we're not going
to defend anything
now so capturing the pawn is a little
bit too much let's try to include in the
defense the queen on the sixth string
queen b6 now queen g4
the queen is getting
now
any captures here are going to end up
very badly because this is like a very
unpleasant threat
i mean what you can do here
i mean the bishop does not have square
if it goes to e5 knight take on c3 and
the bishop is hanging if it goes to f8
probably we're going to go
knight of six probably is winning
basically everything
queen d7 oh your queen is seven at least
you have queen six but knight f6
probably is winning on the back rank so
uh after queen g4 let's try to make some
attempts to defend like okay this morph
is also bad because this is a rather
obvious you know trapping of all the of
the pieces no
now let's try something more natural
like to defend the set the seventh rank
like with rook g7 here queen h4 with a
tempo
h
we are threatening also h6 which is a
problem so if you capture here
knight f6 well
this is because of the pin along the e
file and it's a rather disturbing one no
knight f6 and what else i have written
here on d3 and just h6 and then again
the same thing knight f6 so a lot of
motors and tao probably
you know could have seen many of them h6
we just play
knight f6
and now we have okay if i take on g5
what we what is going to be
knight on g5
do we have a checkmate
right
19
maybe
yeah queen g5 queen g5
queen f6 no
no if you take on g5 i'm looking to see
some kind of a checkmate
how it's going to be
if you take on g5
[Music]
queen
98
check
yeah knight f6 here let me take and take
a look
why
why should i play
knight f6 here
can i just capture i capture on g6 i
should be winning but knight f6
i put this move as winning here
so why and if i capture
on g5
i've been looking here to see
how
they are winning
here
yeah but it's not a checkmate in my
opinion
oh bishop f6
yeah
well maybe we can play a little bit
easier just capturing here and keeping
like a big advantage in my opinion but
at night of six
maybe okay let's take another look maybe
i'm missing something
um
yeah what i'm missing
here just the queen is just going to
step step aside
like here let's say what is a safe place
let's say here
yeah
we need some time to think oh maybe not
here because the rook can take okay
let's find it a better place
probably on okay queen here for example
wins because i'm attacking too many the
knight this is hanging on the eight but
maybe queen john now
what can you do about capturing on g6
basically nothing no i'm going to give
you this checkmate yeah so you need some
time to think it over and then you're
going to find and some of them i have
not mentioned here because okay
i mean when you have time they seem you
know obvious so the defense like i've
been telling you after queen music queen
g4 looks you know really difficult now i
haven't looked at this line getting back
with the knight but it looks you know
really very shaky situation here the
black king i've looked at bishop b4 but
probably take it on g6 i have a look
because at least the knight gets into
defense so that's why bishop f4 to
prevent knight e5 and then on 95 we just
capture it and play knight g5 in a big
accident on the light squares or if you
play knight a5 and then bishop f7 and
steal the black king he's in a very
difficult way so the defense practically
even for such a great blitz player and
such a great champion and a super
defender like karpov it was difficult
that's why at the end he'll got
checkmate in a very brutal way so here
difficult to choose so he chose to
capture on h5
queen take on h5 the rook on e8 is under
attack let's not forget about that so
you don't have time to catch something
on c3 in rook f8 and now
tao played for you know the most
authentic checkmate now maybe knight g3
objectively is better but okay we can't
criticize such a blitz game not so he
played bishop cito with a very simple
thread to give checkmate on a7 now queen
e5
trying to use the pin motif is a kind of
a defensive idea but tao could not be
stopped because here after queen e5 he
played knight g3 he gives away even but
kim wants to give carpo finally a
checkmate well probably after so many
years he was really you know
a longing yearning for gift checkmate
carpenter and finally he gave him a very
good checkmate now after king h2
objectively here the defense is
basically practically impossible
not only in a bliss game maybe even in
an active chess game maybe in a normal
game you can fight some so the only move
was to find bishop h6
and after we capture here like if we
capture with the queen we can play rook
f7 if you capture with the bishop it
looks completely winning we have the
only defense
rook f7 and after this move which looks
like the end of the game take a look
because if you capture here you got
checkmate on the back ring if you
capture with the king you got checkmated
okay now check mate but your queen is
missed so here i have to move bishop a7
which probably carp of saw such lies and
after you play rook f7 bishop deaconess
you have to film a move like rook c6 but
practically
with a
you know absolutely vulnerable king on
the h1 this is practically impossible so
here
maybe carp also look at some other lines
in this position like rook f6
queen eight checkmate on the back ring
then he saw it if he captures on c3
bishop g7
and
the battery gives you checkmate in a
very efficient way like a staircase no
and checkmate now maybe he also looked
here after king h2 he maybe also looked
after
this move let's say here bishop take on
a6 maybe he looked at the move like
queen c3 he also saw that he was getting
checkmate in the same way and he told it
okay there is no way to play bishop a6
because virtually it was very hard to
find any kind of you know
uh
defense here and probably he saw in my
opinion that there is such a move
bishop take on a7 and that's why we came
with the move h6 although it's not
saving anything and it still got
you know check made it so he played h6
in this blitz game bishop take on h6 by
tao here there is no way back if you
play let's say rook g6
then discover check and after you cover
because okay this of course i mean it's
also a checkmate not even mentioning
that your queen is missing all the time
and so if you play rook a6 here let's
say here bishop take on a6 and again
threatening checkmate so you're not
saving anything
so after bishop take on a6 karpov played
king j
and here
you know
tar finally gave him a very good
checkmate bishop take on g7 now if you
capture back
you receive the typical checkmate no
the battery are working perfectly and
you've got checkmate on a7 and you take
one f2 of course this complete
desperation and the player bishop is
going to give you checkmate in many many
ways so karpov played
rook take on f2 and he got checked mate
like that and queen g6 here
bishop basics and here
one move before
getting checkmated
carpool resign so this is a very
spectacular win by the great mikio tao
and in my opinion it gives you know a
very you know bright light about all the
ideas of this exchange sacrifice on e6
and just to continue to give you a
little bit
some you know curious information
the first time at the beginning of our
lecture what i told you i saw the
sacrifice was in 1994 at the olympia on
moscow and olympia and moscow although
we won against russia with
uh kasparov kramnik and all the best
players still at the end they became
world champions but i have one curious
detail about playing russia because okay
first they were sovereign union but but
then
after the olympia in manila when there
were many teams from the ex-soviet union
they started you know to be you know the
official team of russia
so against russia there is this curious
detail that i've played fought not three
times against russia in a matches
bulgaria against russia and some of the
other participants which have scored
some very impressive wins they have
played in more matches but i've quite
curiously i played three times against
russia without winning a game i've
played i think two draws with fiddler
one with the uh
what was his name is veginsev and one
once i lost with black against grishok
having a nice position but okay then he
played a very good game and i
played a couple of really bad in
precision so in this three match against
russia quite curiously because being now
inactive i'm not going to play anymore
matches bulgaria 130. so basically
probably this makes me it doesn't make
do not have like a practical purpose
what i'm telling but it's a curious fact
it makes me the only player who stands
with the 100 3-0 against russia
and this is not going to change because
i'm not going to play any more
team matches against russia all the
other participants who's caught some
very impressive wins like topalov like
spoke they have participated in some
other matches and in these other matches
bulgaric has lost against russia but at
least i have very
you know good memories of the matches
playing with russia because they have
ended
3-0 and i think the result of these
three matches was
two wins by two and a half against one
and a half and one one classical win
three three one which was quite
impressive and in one of these
uh matches at this olympiad in moscow 94
after the match in which they lost two
and a half one and a half i mean the
first boat topolo
with white checkmated kasparov on the
seventh ring one very impressive win on
the second brought kramnik one with
white
the theoretical battle win one long
theory in the slav against georgiev on
the third both i made a draw with
fiddler without getting even having
slightly better pictures on this
exchange exchange line of the
of the
scotch with the four knights i call this
line this the highlander which is e4e5
e5 knight f396 knights 396 d4
capturing bishop b4 and i've played it
very often it's a quite dry position and
i now even started to play something
different in black to have a little bit
more interesting position and the
forward board spasuf i won the match by
an impressive win against the draft and
after the match which they have lost and
in the end the olympian they become
olympia champions to be true after the
match it was a very nice picture to look
all the russian team with kasparov and
all the other politicians like romney
being in one corner of the of the of the
big theater and looking very sad i
remember this on this side so okay some
memories of course are here to stay so
thank you for all the attention i hope
you got a good idea about this
positional exchange sacrifice on e6 and
then you have in my opinion some very
good
examples to look after because i mean
one of the greatest chess player that
ever existed without any doubt was
mikhail tao so thank you and
are looking forward to the next thursday
to continue
with
some
interesting practical ideas all the best
see you very soon bye bye
[Music]
you